sind sekunden bis zu den ersten zahlen
und im moment sieht es so aus dass sagen
die letzten umfragen dass das ein cdu
wahlerfolg werden könnte bei dem die
frage besteht ob sie aber wirklich
regieren kann und jetzt kommen die
ersten zahlen rein und die sagen dass
die cdu auf 35 prozent der stimmen kommt
jubel aktuell hier wir können auch noch
eine horchen auf die cdu wahlparty die
spd nur auf
27,5 prozent der stimmen und die fdp
mitregiert im moment noch die straße an
der fünf prozent hürde das könnte ein
ganz bitterer wahlabend für die fdp
werden die iaaf jeweils sechs prozent
die grünen bei 18 5 gigantischer wahl
erfolgt für die grünen und das sind die
entscheidenden gesichter dazu claus
strunz mit dem schnellsten wahl
kommentar hierbei bild live cdu 35 spd
27,5 deine einschätzung was fallenden
wahl schlappe für schwarz-gelb diese
koalition hat ja in nrw regiert wie wir
wissen ist komplett abgewählt was für
eine schlappe für olaf scholz
27,5 prozent das ist wirklich
abenteuerlich geschichtsträchtig
schlechtes ergebnis für die spd in
nordrhein westfalen
das ist auch eine schlappe für ihn als
bundeskanzler das ist natürlich eine
schlappe für den kandidaten dort aber
olaf scholz entwickelt sich immer mehr
offensichtlich zum wähler schreck er ist
ein kanzler einer kanzlerpartei aber
ohne kanzlerbonus mehr noch es scheint
ein kanzler malus zu sein und ein wort
vielleicht noch zu der größten säule
glückwunsch an hendrik wüst der hat die
zeit nach armin laschet von niederlage
in sieg verwandelt mal sehen ob auch
regieren kann und jetzt schauen wir ganz
schnell auf die wichtigsten balken
dieses abends schauen sie drauf auf die
zahlen die erste prognose aus
nordrhein-westfalen noch mal ganz
schnell zum mitschreiben zuhause großer
schwarzer balken heute für die cdu das
ist ein wahlerfolg für den amtierenden
ministerpräsidenten trikot ist aktuell
35 prozent der stimmen das sagt die
erste prognose
27,5 nur für die spd und da ist
interessant von woody kam die waren ja
auch bei der bundestagswahl ganz stark
vorne in nordrhein westfalen da war
ganze bundesland rot und jetzt eben nur
noch 27 5 die grünen 18 5 gum tischer
wahlerfolg heute für die grünen die
haben sich mal locker wie claus strunz
gerade schon gesagt hat verdreifacht in
dieser landtagswahl in nordrhein
westfalen
das wird ganz entscheidend sein für den
weiteren verlauf dieses abends denn die
werden am ende möglicherweise
entscheidend sein für die regierung denn
wir erzählen wir schnell zusammen das
könnte könnte könnte hier eben auch noch
reichen jetzt aktualisiert sich das
gerade weil eine neue zahlen
reingekommen sind das könnte erreichen
für rot grün ja sieht im moment nicht
danach aus aber könnte noch reichen
ansonsten läuft das ganz klar auf
schwarz grün hinaus und dann schauen wir
auch das ist interessant auf die kleinen
balken hier und da eine der ist so
geschrumpft das dicke sorgenfalten im
gesicht von christian lindner entstehen
fünf prozent nur noch für die fdp die
hat ja da regiert in nordrhein westfalen
das ist ganz ganz bitter regieren tut
offenbar richtig wie für die fdp dass
das ergebnis denn die liegen nach der
ersten prognose sogar hinter der afg
klaus also noch mal ganz in ruhe auf
diese zahlen drauf geguckt hier sehen
wir auch noch mal gewinne und verluste
des heutigen abends und da sehen wir
dann eben noch deutlicher wie im moment
die
gewinne und verluste verteilt sind also
cdu ganz klar zwei nach oben und die
grünen sind der gigantische wahlsieger
dieses abends klaus was ergibt sich
daraus für den bund für die ampel für
olaf scholz und co naja wir schauen wir
auf die ampelfarben das ist eigentlich
in dieser grafik die wir eben gesehen
haben alles drin die spd ist eine grosse
wahlverliererin des heutigen abends das
auch noch in nordrhein westfalen ein
einstiges hochburg land der spd und die
absoluten gewinner sind die grünen das
ist schon sehr sehr faszinierend sie
bestimmen offenbar zu recht auch die
regierungspolitik in berlin
offensichtlich sind annalena baerbock
und robert habeck die politiker figuren
der jetztzeit die es schaffen die
menschen dazu zu bringen dass die grünen
auch wirklich gemacht werden es sei
absurd weil eigentlich sind die grünen
die partei
pazifisten die jetzt
hat die pisten die jetzt waffen liefern
ich sehe gerade jetzt sind die grünen
die gehört nicht einfach das wort können
wir ganz erreichen
höhe der zeit zu machen für die menschen
in nordrhein westfalen für die
wirtschaft in nordrhein westfalen
natürlich ist das ein
wahnsinniger rückhalt für das was wir
für die menschen in nrw gestalten wollen
und unsere fans haben wir hier noch
trank wein vor zwei jahren angefangen
jeden tag zu leben in den kommunen mit
landesweit 20 prozent mit ehrenamtlichen
grünen die jeden tag die probleme im
status quo lösen für die menschen in
ihren städten und gemeinden darüber
haben wir vertrauen gewonnen ich danke
allen in der steuerungsgruppe ich danke
dem landesvorstand ich danke den
abgeordneten aus dem landtag ich denke
natürlich unseren vertreterinnen
vertretern in berlin in europa aber vor
allem sieht es mir nach ich bin halt
noch parteivorsitzende alle 26000
mitglieder dieses landesverbandes das
ist also die grüne spitzenkandidatin
neubauer nordrhein westfalen die
eigentliche wahlsiegerin dieses abends
neben der cdu natürlich claus strunz
unser bild live chef da kannst du dir
das erklären nordrhein westfalen ist er
jetzt vielleicht auch nicht das
stammland der grünen ja und da räumen
die heute ab da verdreifachen die da mal
eben ihr wahlergebnis und die fdp
gleichzeitig die schrumpft fast zur
unkenntlichkeit zusammen das ist ganz
offensichtlich so dass die grünen es
schaffen als die partei der jetztzeit
bei den menschen anzukommen und jetzt
schauen wir halt mal rein das ist
schizophren denn die grünen sind ja eine
partei eine pazifistische partei die
zurzeit waffen liefert und sie sind eine
partei die auf ökologische energie setzt
auf eine ökowende und die grad sozusagen
in der welt umherreist um fossile
energieträger zu organisieren also eine
doppelt falsch aufgestellte partei im
moment die bei den menschen aber ankommt
und was könnte das geheimnis sein sie
wirkt so als hätte sie als hätte sie als
hätten habeck und baerbock als hätten
sie einen plan und eine idee von der
zukunft und ich glaube darum geht es
zurzeit ich glaube es wird eine idee der
zukunft gewünscht und gewählt das haben
die grünen perfekt im repertoire
obwohl sie selbstsicher 180 grad wenden
müssen um der jetztzeit gerecht zu
werden jetzt verbinden wir das
wahlergebnis heute natürlich auch mit
den spitzen köpfen hier in berlin also
der etwas geschrumpfte spd balken mit
olaf scholz der verdreifachte balken
grün mit robert habeck und annalena
baerbock und der geschrumpfte kleine
winzige gelbe balken mit christian
lindner was bedeutet das für diese vier
in dieser regierungskonstellation also
der eine christian lindner brutal
abgestraft der ein bisschen olaf scholz
und die anderen massiv gestärkt ja wir
stellen uns einfach vor der sich die
herrschaften morgen treffen und da
kommen zwei mit ganz vielen muskeln also
wahrscheinlich wie heißt diese grüne
figur halb ist nicht halb diese grüne
figur mit den dicken muskeln die kaum
jemand besiegen kann so kommen morgen
annalena baerbock und robert habeck in
die gespräche olaf scholz kommt als olaf
scholz schweigsam klein zurückhaltend
wahrscheinlich kommentierte auch das
nicht wir alles nicht kommentiert und
wenn das kommentiert merkt es keiner
oder erreichte die menschen damit nicht
und christian lindner ist eigentlich die
interessanteste figur in diesem spiel er
selber war ja mal spitzenkandidat in
nordrhein westfalen der lief es für die
fdp sehr sehr viel besser in der zeit
nach ihm läuft es offensichtlich sehr
sehr sehr sehr viel schwächer aber er
ist nicht ein parteichef und ist der der
finanzminister also das kräfteverhältnis
unserer bundesregierung hat sich nach
der wahlentscheidung der menschen in
nordrhein westfalen der am tisch
verändert mit folgen die wir heute noch
gar nicht richtig einschätzen können in
der zwischenzeit zwischen bundestagswahl
und landtagswahl hat die spd dramatisch
verloren in nordrhein westfalen noch
wenn sie jetzt gar nicht so unerreichbar
weit weg von der cdu ist und noch bei 27
5 jahr deutlich über dem bundestrend
aber die hat in der zeit richtig dick
verloren wer wäre es so gewesen wenn
olaf scholz jetzt nicht reagiert hätte
in diesen sechs monaten das heute der
ministerpräsidentin es in nordrhein
westfalen ein spd mann wäre das kann das
kann vielleicht sein fest steht dass die
spd in der kanzlerzeit von olaf scholz
landtagswahlen verliert ist ja schon die
zweite auch in schleswig holstein hat es
für die spd nicht geklappt jetzt klappt
das auch in großen wichtigen land
nordrhein-westfalen nicht das ist ja
schon ein signal der bürger dass sie
unzufriedenheiten dafür spüren
interessant ist aber dass olaf scholz
wenn ich alles richtig sehe ja zum
beispiel in der frage der unterstützung
der ukraine
mehrheitsmeinung der deutschen finden
nämlich wir müssen aufpassen dass wir in
diesen krieg mit reingezogen werden
deshalb eher defensive bei der
waffenlieferung das meinen und fühlen da
die mehrheit der deutschen bürger auch
aber er scheint es nicht kommuniziert zu
kriegen jedenfalls verbinden ist die
menschen nicht mit der spd sonst kämen
solche ergebnisse nichts zustande also
er vertritt sagst du eigentlich die
mehrheitsmeinung und trotzdem ist es
immer unbeliebter ja und das ist ein
phänomen das wahrscheinlich in der
persönlichkeitsstruktur und in dem ja
charisma defizit von olaf scholz liegt
dass er nicht schafft die menschen hier
zu erreichen und es dann seinen kollegen
in den ländern damit schleswig holstein
und nordrhein westfalen sehr schwer
machen und umgekehrt annalena baerbock
und robert habeck vertreten offenbar
demnach dann nicht immer die
mehrheitsmeinung und gleichzeitig
gewinnen sie aber dramatisch an
beliebtheit immer dazu im moment die top
drei minister im bund sind alles grüne
ja und erfolg macht sexy das gilt
sicherlich auch für die grünen da muss
man jetzt schon genau hinschauen was die
richtig machen und wir können ja zum
beispiel machen lassen einmal den
vergleich weil sich ja auch schwarz grün
anbahnt machen mit der cdu bei der cdu
sehe ich halt doch für die zukunft
nur männer in tragenden rollen friedrich
merz ist der parteichef wo ist da weit
und breit eine frau zu sehen wo ist da
weit und breit in jüngerer zu sehen dann
gewinnen
daniel günther und hendrik wüst die
länder das ist next generation gar keine
frage männer
und das zukunftsversprechen also doch
auch eine gewisse diversität abzubilden
mit einer mutigen innovativen idee auf
die zukunft zu gehen ich persönlich
finde viele der ideen der grünen
gehen in die falsche richtung aber mir
imponiert dass sie ideen haben mit denen
man sich auseinandersetzen kann und das
ist eine aufforderung an die anderen
parteien dem endlich auch gerät farbe zu
bekennen